well especially given there's no increments
so there's no help coming right this is like a
this is a wild west style affair
well even though i'm not really sure how rain
would feel about being cast as the sith hicaro
this is some pretty good pretty good fan artwork
here right yeah it's really really well done you
see rain here you see sardo's you see kevin
board you see um you see chiyu uh then there's
yoda i'm not quite sure who yoda is exactly but
um there's yoda here too um and uh and it is it
is chess wars and we are ready to roll i think
sardo send it up his final prayers to the chess
god save your breath sardosh i've been praying to
the chess gods for years look where it's gotten me
viva la france that's what that's all i'm going
to say i bet everything on i just bet everything
on sardo so he better not let me down okay well
um picard have you ever prayed to the chess guys
did they answer your prayer or not mine is that
what happened um no i mean generally i don't do
that i i think the only thing i will say is that
sometimes there are some superstitions i have
you know i think i've noticed sardosh has al has
worn the same shirt right yeah i think he's worn
the same shirt during every match so he does i
don't maybe he just wears the same shirt every
day because i mean we know there's a certain
other uh french-speaking streamer who does
that so maybe maybe i mean starters is trying to
try just just trying to model after him but i do
think sargeras has worn the same shirt for every
match i i we should ask him afterwards especially
if he wins if that's the reason it's because he's
uh he's superstitious now i was a3 is a good move
by by ray now i think i'm kind of curious to see
will starters go back to e7 or will they go to a5
and actually in a way i kind of prefer
a5 i think it's a little bit easier
um to get the bishop to b6 it feels like the
peace placement is pretty good for for black here
this is a nervous moment for rayne wilson
where he's he's he's nearing two minutes
taken on the clock and still hasn't played the
only move oh oh he plays knight c5 it's still
it's it's a good move it's still a move though
he can play the other order i would have traded
them on knight c5 he can still do it this way too
though and sardoche with knight to b4 this is a
big moment this could be the game right here if
rain doesn't solve this problem correctly jakarta
absolutely and i'm not surprised that sardosh
found it it was it was a move that was sort of
screaming to be played and um and now for rain
he has to find which rook square to where to
move his rook rookie 2 is actually a great move
by the way fantastic move so sardo should should
look to take advantage of the a file here even
something like bishop b5 and offering the trade
that's one of the fastest ways to take advantage
of disconnected pieces but he plays nicely too
again not so clear though because black can take
and go rook a2 it still still is unclear so that
and that's the other thing i would say is so i
would feel like more at the intermediate level
or beginner level if there's an open file i think
actually having a rook against the bishop tonight
generally is preferable um because it's a lot
easier to just use the world versus coordinating
the bishop in the night now um seize it and
now it gets spicy this is going to get super
spicy sardosh might even end up because at less
experienced levels everyone even though the night
and bishop are objectively better look at what's
happening rain is rain is not it's it's wait he
didn't play what what whoa what yeah they're both
just missing g4 it's hanging what are they doing
what the g4 is hanging on the board oh my
gosh what is going on here oh man that was
and now he now he almost is losing the pieces
i think sardo's just panicked i honestly
think sergio is just panicked there he saw his
clock was getting low and he just panicked yeah
wow he just missed his winning opportunity we
didn't think we'd see evil bar swings like that
but now if right right if rayne finds the
plan of getting the knight in then white
should still be winning but he's already missed
it a few times and in fact here you go again
what i was trying to say is it's so much
harder to coordinate the knight and bishop
for less experienced players than it is to play
with the rook and we're seeing that here even
though reigns better he's not coordinating
the miners the way you know a master would
obviously yeah that's the thing it's like because
you think about it it's two-for-one yeah and now
you don't take the bishop on e1 it's important
just like water is broke oh my god oh my gosh
if sardocia had taken the pawn or given check
he might have come back and won that game you
panicked you know it was like sir dosh i think
it's just too much too much in the way of nerves
he was defending for so long yeah that when he
had the opportunity just he eventually cracked
under the pressure of the situation but let's
see let's see um yeah yeah just knight takes pawn
very rough very rough for um for sara dosh i
mean like he he he really kept it together but
i think it was just the comb it was the pressure
of being worse on the board and the pressure of
the clock as well and just it got to him he just
couldn't keep it together past a certain point
um and it was like right when he was back it was
right when it turned around the wonder occurred
um so i yeah you know i think i think
it's just one of those things where
i don't even know how you're supposed to look
at it because he's done this twice now with the
backwards night capture but maybe there's just
some way to just double double check and see i
don't see where your night is or something i'm not
i'm not really sure how he can do it but the fact
that it's not the first time is is um is a bad
sign yeah yeah well and he he had gotten himself
in a position where the rook was was flexing on
the knight and bishop and reign and we talked
about sardosh missing the opportunity but you
know reign was going backwards with the pieces
and the knight and bishop were not doing what
they were supposed to so really unfortunate to
see sardosh miss the the night capture and unless
rain pulls uh let's rain pulls a stalemate here
oh my god when you play 25 for a second i thought
he did oh man look at the sardosh oh man yeah well
i mean i mean we all we all knew it was it was
a good job yesterday that's all i'm gonna say
reign's approach in general is he just kind
of wants to get to the middle game he's not
into the opening stuff so that's why most
of my opening advice is how not to lose um
is it going to play the hippopotamus with e6
and 97.97 oh wow this this is the thing rain
loves but this is gonna this could get him in
big trouble and i think this might have been
what kevin was coaching sardoshan like look if he
gives you the center take it and don't apologize
yeah exactly so um yeah i mean pretty pretty
balanced position white has much more space
in the center of the board it's very hard
to play here um for both sides i feel like
because neither side really has a clear break um
black can't play e5 like black normally does uh
f5 is probably too dubious because of knight
q5 so it's going to be interesting to see
um how rain how rain reacts here it's also
going to be really important that sardosh
keeps it together though he's really got
to stay focused um and i think not fall too
far behind on the clock so i think the clock is
really what hurt him the most in the first game
this is a pawn that while it looks good could end
up being a disaster for rain exactly i mean again
i think for starters plays queenie too great move
as long as starters keeps it together here and he
doesn't doesn't panic and freak out too much he
still is has a very good chance to win this game
yeah the risk of d5 ray might play d5 but the
risk is then the dark squares are problematic
and you've got new problems again it's anyone's
game though i feel like i i feel like the the the
the uh the weakness of the black king
here gives sardosh good chances regardless
even though even though objectively it was a bad
move uh oh he's got rook c6 he's got rook c6 okay
six huge well he also cuts off the queen from b5
by the way which is officially a threat for black
yeah rook c6 is a huge move will he find it if he
finds rookie i think he's going to win this game
what a move this is it well
sardo's play rook takes he does
nice i think i think we're headed to overtime oh
what is that oh no what is that by rain yeah oh
well now rain just loses rick takes rook and you
just oh and now you resign now you just resign
so this was super tough for it was super tough
for raymond because of how sardoche played it i
mean honestly he kept the pressure rook c1 wasn't
as good as knight d2 but in hindsight the idea
was just as strong and and he's gonna take this
wow yeah you know i was gonna say that um a lot
of credit goes to sergio she kept it together
like you could tell he was really frustrated
when he hung that pawn on c4 um there are a
lot of movements and gesticulations and all
those other things but he kept it together and he
didn't completely lose it and he still made moves
logical moves didn't spend too much time um and
he's gonna he's gonna win this game now i think
well we called it then we said that's going to be
a pawn that he's happy is gone look at the c file
it's winning in the game now queenie five maybe 25
yep yeah and that's all she wrote very nice finish
got nervous there for like a second i mean if
if rainey got here i don't know what would have
happened yeah but yeah yeah he's got he's
gonna win now especially because as i said
before it's a bishop i don't think he's
speaking english or french he's speaking
yeah the good thing is that it's a bishop it's a
bishop so bishop can only attack on you know the
dark dark colored tiles and therefore uh there's
no chance of of sardosh not winning here it's
like 99.99 percent guaranteed he will win so we're
gonna head to uh to blitz gonna be blitz overtime
where i think sort of has to be the favorite um
i believe there it does matter who gets who gets
white and i believe sardosh will get white i think
it is decided by rating but we'll confirm that so
um wow yeah there's just no way because i as
i've noticed if you get a bishop that's the one
end game where your tricks even even if even in
the consolation bracket if you end up with like
a rookie against a bishop the bishop just does
not attack you can only attack on one color of
squares so it's it's not it's it's not you
just you can't create threats with a bishop
so there's just no way that sardosh doesn't win
sir dosh cleans this up i'll uh i'll clean up
what was a discussion for the community just so
you know the donations were coming in so fast
that the animation fell behind the bar so just
so you know a lot of the donations flashing now
that we already shot out and i and i gave a shout
out to you before you were not being ignored just
you guys got way ahead of the animation so
um so it took a while to catch up but again
uh thank you to everyone and i think we're
going to have overtime so on poisson right
on cue there's on poisson and then you know
you see the lolly checkmate on b7 yep but the
bar is accurate in real time just so you
know the bar is accurate for donations
just like uh it takes a frenchman to not miss
on not win uh miss on poisson right of course
okay i think sardosh is probably gonna go right
back to it with some kind of improvement from
kevin if i had to guess yeah i would definitely
agree with that all right so here we go
now once again this is 5-0 so it's it's and the
other thing i would say is i suspect that uh
that sardosh has not played much blitz because his
rating is one thousand and four where his reign
is 1385 but but then again reign is 13.85 is that
based on a significant significant amount of games
or just like one or two is also it's only based on
one or two and his in his main account he's about
11 50. so okay um he's you know what that's based
on it's based on basically whatever armageddon
games he's had here in this event um which he's
won every tiebreaker right that's true yep okay so
let's see okay so bishop e2 well sardo's go d4 is
a big question mark too yeah d4 is going to move
well i think it's an e447 right okay this
should be seven completely reasonable so far
i will say i think this this opening is a little
bit favorable to black because i feel like white's
ideas are not so obvious here if white doesn't
play d4 and four's open this diagonal like if
white goes d3 i think blacksmiths are a little
bit easier with like rookie 8 and bish buffet
pretty dicey already for rain
down a minute on the clock
um well especially given there's no increments
so there's no help coming right this is like a
this is a wild west style affair especially when
you were just playing a bunch of increment it's
hard to make that adjustment but at the same time
both of these guys have had tie breakers and right
for sardosh it took a tie breaker to get here you
know so um we know that they know what's in store
right so now will rain finally play d4 the
last moment that he can play d4 will he do it
will he do it if he doesn't starters goes
d4 and you open up the long diagonal and
you excavate the knight on f3 and the pawn on g2
yeah so he does go d4 good move yeah the this if
rayne doesn't play 95 here i think he's probably
gonna lose okay he does but he's had two moments
had to find 95 and he found him both
times but again two minutes on the clock
yeah i mean i think for rain this is this is
really hard to play because the bishop on b2 is
bad black has the obvious lever with f6 to remove
that knight from e5 um and the queen and bishop
also are on c7 and d6 which are lined up very
neatly here yeah i want to see if starters finds
f6 here which is a very good yeah f6 or even c3
first are both really good but i think f6 is just
kind of you know yeah i don't i don't want to
say obvious but when you just move the knight
it's got to be on his on his agenda and
indeed sardosh finds it this guy this guy
has just gotten so good over this last month
and he's playing this blitz game like a boss
yeah it's it's really weird it's like when sardo
doesn't have time to think when he doesn't let his
his like mind like start to you know mess with
his confidence he just plays free-flowing chess
he plays a lot better and i think that's
actually true of a lot of people the last
time they had to think and start like being
insecure and worrying about this or that
the the better they play when they just
can't think it's just like they just move
you just play the game you don't let your brain
like disturb you and and mess up everything
well now rain is really getting down on
the clock and this is probably going to be
the story not not even just because of
the clock but he's also much worse on
the board so it would take a blunder by
sardosh probably to give rain chances
yeah c3 here is very strong i think d3 and knight
she five but oh knight d5 oh no he blundered
does reigns see it knight
this is his last chance it's
gonna come down to the wire
but now king oh my god
all the way back perhaps the most epic and wild
ending you could ask for in an overtime tiebreaker
a surprise checkmate but before we get into that
good news for you both community rally got us over
fifty thousand dollars so matched with a hundred
thousand by chess.com we have a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars going to charity and a lot of
it was driven on this last day so amazing amazing
stuff thank you guys and tell us more just about
you know how much you enjoyed playing the event
your your you know how much you love chess and you
know how was this experience playing in pogchamps
this event sucked chess sucks france sucks
no man uh this is a lot of fun man it was listen
i'm an old i'm an old dude and i was for a little
while on the high school chess team wasn't very
good um but to get to dive in and re-examine
the game in a fresh way was a lot of fun and
i'm really excited for the money that we made
uh for our non-profit sardosh if you want to
donate any of your winnings over to our charity
you're welcome my friend um and played some great
players along the way had a great experience
and um thrilled to be a part of it and
just big congratulations to sartosh on his
victory sardosh same question to you just
tell us your final thoughts on playing in pog
champs and uh and where where you're going
from here with your with your chess career
um first of all out of all my esport career i
played some great league of legends tournaments
i played some great twitch
rewards on many games but
out of everything that that was the win i was
the most happy with like i i i will actually
fade out when i won this game it was too much to
under i never felt something like this this this
it has been like two months i'm literally
discovering the game and getting obsessed
with it and i play like maybe 12 hours a day for
like two months so i'm i'm doing for four hours of
puzzle you can make it like it i i went to 2100
and like i play six hours again every day just
sometimes never get out of my bed and pay my phone
uh that was something i really was focused on so
i'm so proud i want it and i know i will chill a
bit i will i will focus on another thing i will
play a bit of forget league and stuff like this
but i will never forget chess and play it's until
i get at least two thousand sometimes and i mean
who can say i eat those levels some some day in my
life i think that will be a really good life goal
and i will definitely am for it at some point here
and play on the board by the way would be awesome
yeah i don't think i've ever done anything for 12
hours a day so that's pretty incredible and
you earned it man thank you guys both so much
and again thank you to the community who came
through in the clutch and got us over that 150
000 raised marker and the two largest percentages
going to reign in sardosh's uh charities
respectively but remember all of the participants
get a percentage to the charities that they chose
which is incredible so guys what a wild ride
thank you so much for doing this congratulations
to you both congrats sardoche and uh maybe
a future pog champs and we'll see you then
what a what a pog champs way to end it
with a 92 surprise checkmate on the board
yeah it was i mean it was a great finish
it's sort of that game swung back and forth
the whole match swung back and forth the
way that he took it so seriously and then
it comes through win that second game then win
the tiebreaker i was just really really special
so sardosh that the hard work paid off and an
incredible and deserving pogchamps champion there
you